well I think the key thing that we're
missing today that we had before were
people who were saying what is it gonna
be like in 20 30 years and that spirit
is gone California is sort of becoming a
crotchety old man you know California's
water crisis is the disaster everybody
saw coming but nobody had the power to
stop it's the byproduct of a broken
political culture the doing of
self-serving elites and misguided
ideologues so says Joel Kotkin a
distinguished professor at Chapman
University and an expert on the Golden
State so basically we just haven't
prepared for the inevitable it's almost
like you know having a kid and deciding
that you're gonna stop buying clothes
after they turn eight California is a
creation of engineering I mean it's a
state with very fertile soils and huge
topographical differences but that means
that you're very vulnerable to something
happening like not enough snow in the
Sierra to really hurt most of the state
so you have to continue to invest in the
engineering side and I think the
business community in California did not
push for that and the green frankly to
them the less bored of the better
between the years of 1999 and 2007
roughly 185 dams were removed in the
Golden State with each dam that is torn
down California's water storage goes
down and the cost of energy goes up
environmentalists further exacerbated
the water crisis in an effort to protect
a type of tiny fish called the delta
smelt
that's on the endangered species list
agricultural pumps on the Sacramento
River Delta were sucking up and killing
the delta smelt so environmentalists
successfully fought to turn off the
pumps the result is that water that was
being used to irrigate crops is instead
flowing straight to the ocean you know
you can shut down suburbia you can shut
down big agriculture and you can limit
population growth in the state which is
exactly what most greens would probably
would like to see Kotkin says another
cause of the current crisis is that
politicians distorted water market
prices for farmers farmers have got to
you know pay something closer to a
market rate on their own water
I mean it's there's no point in our
growing alfalfa and sending it to China
we might as well sort of send all our
water to China
we're at it in a very big misconception
is that there's nothing you can do about
it and there's lots of things we can do
about it well I mean certainly there may
be some areas that we could develop of
still in the Sierra there's still a lot
there's a lot of snow it's just we don't
get all of it and maybe there's
something you could do there certainly
you could have more storage and you can
obviously do desalinization you know the
Pacific Ocean is not going to run out of
water for water desalinization is the
process in which large machines take
water from the ocean and remove the salt
making the water usable for agriculture
and drinkable black people but again
many environmentalists oppose
desalinization because they say sea life
will get caught up in the pumps and that
overall the process will be detrimental
to the oceans ecosystem I agree with you
know ideas of you know probably we
shouldn't have big lawns if we can you
know we have a small amount of grass and
you plant desert plants as I did in this
house I mean there are lots of things
that you can do that will help cotton
says that if the state can't fix its
water problems many industries will have
to leave the Golden State destroying
opportunities for poor Californians and
exacerbating and growing class divide
huge populations of the state east of
the of the coast that are among the
poorest populations in the country well
I think what we may see is basically
that that interior California becomes
like upstate New York
another Appalachia
you